la France face à la sécheresse un mois
entier sans pluie c'est un record qui
inquiète évidemment la pluie se fait
attendre 32 jours d'affilée il faut
faire dès à présent des économies d'eau
les mots du ministre de la transition
écologique Christophe Béchu qui détaille
ce matin au Journal du Dimanche sa
stratégie pour une planification de la
gestion de l'eau on a deux mois de
retard sur la recharge des nappes
phréatiques le problème il est d'autant
plus grave qu'on a déjà eu une
sécheresse hivernale l'année dernière et
donc on est sur une situation de nappe
et de difficulté qui est très grande
donc le donc les restrictions vont
s'étendre vous dites on verra en
fonction de la situation
de départements alors c'est des
restrictions d'anticipation Emmanuel
Macron en visite au salon de
l'agriculture à lui aussi appelé à un
plan de sobriété pour lutter contre la
sécheresse sur le modèle de la sobriété
énergétique mais les Français ceux qui
sont femmes de chambre
si jamais on a si jamais vous me faites
rien il y aura des gens qui vont en
prison il s'arrêtera pas il y aura rien
qui nous arrêtera j'ai fini ce que
j'avais à dire vous n'êtes pas on vous a
déjà entendu monsieur non pas pour
réellement en réalité l'interpeller mais
pour en découdre et moi ce que je veux
dire parlementaire c'est pas que ça me
gêne mais en tant que parlementaire je
dis plutôt que d'essayer dans le
découdre venez à nos côtés pour essayer
de résoudre
monsieur mais ne dis pas
que le français c'est pas un débat c'est
pas un débat monsieur c'est pas un débat
c'est pour vous annoncer qu'on ne se
laissera pas faire on ne peut plus
laisser faire la réforme des retraites
ça arrive au Sénat le texte sera étudié
à partir de mardi pour Bruno Retailleau
l'objectif est clair faire mieux qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale la responsabilité
du Sénat de sa majorité comme de son
opposition et de ne pas céder à cette
guignolisation des débats Bruno
Retailleau a présenté ses axes
d'évolution pour le texte suppression
plus rapide des régimes spéciaux et plus
de justice pour les femmes dans la
réforme d'accord et ouvert à travailler
sur ce pour travailler sur ce point-là
je pense que
avoir des âges de départ différentiel
entre les femmes et les hommes ça n'est
pas très juste et je partage totalement
la vie de Bruno Retailleau et les
positions qu'il a exprimé ce matin dans
le Parisien me paraissent essentiel la
première d'entre elles c'est la lutte
contre les injustices qui restent dans
cette réforme et on a beaucoup parlé des
carrières longues mais les carrières
c'est pas le seul sujet d'injustice
comme je vois essentiellement c'est ça
je vois une immense injustice mais
comment ne pas la voir d'ailleurs je
veux bien mais brute retaillaux à la
différence de un certain nombre de
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle n'est pas n'est pas
sénateur que depuis une mandature ils
sont là depuis un certain temps donc moi
ce que je dis c'est plutôt que de
rentrer dans des querelles partisanes
voyons comment on peut enrichir le texte
et oui le texte doit pouvoir être
enrichi j'ai vu qu'il voulait faire
avancer les choses sur politique
familiale et les droits des femmes
et donc je pense que le gouvernement
abordera avec de l'ouverture et de la
volonté d'engager pour bâtir une
majorité derrière ce texte petit matin
dans le port de Frontignan des chars qui
débarquent hier déjà dans le ciel de
Castres des centaines de parachutistes
qui sont largués r mais terre cyber
participe à cette entraînement et le
terrain est immense 14 départements du
sud de la France on est un exercice si
toutefois il devait avoir une guerre en
dix ans ou dans 15 ans nous devons être
prêts et donc nous nous préparons la
buvette ça va devenir un problème estime
une députée Renaissance certains
commandent des coupettes des 11 heures
du matin d'autres sont au rhum à 16h au
début de l'examen du texte j'ai vu un
député se faire ramasser par les
serveurs de la buvette tellement il
était mal Palmade victime d'un AVC hier
soir à l'hôpital Paul Brousse de
Villejuif sont pronostic vital n'est pas
engagé dans la buvette et dans les
jardins c'était Alco la gogo jusqu’à 3
heures du matin mais ça vous fait rire
la cour d'appel tranchera demain sur le
placement ou non en détention provisoire
de l'humoriste parmi les députés il y a
des toxicomanes et des alcooliques c'est
comme un peu les français veut dire
c'est un peu à l'image du parti du pays
ne t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas